so Neil's got a sample of sodium sodium
is a very reactive metal it's stored
under an oil to stop air or moisture
getting on it
stop it oxidizing and stop it reacting
you can see it's a very soft metal so
he's going to put his knife in and
withdraw the lump of sodium so there's
about two kilos of sodium here it's a
really quite large rod so we're going to
cut a small of it small sample of the
sodium and we're going to see if we can
explore some of its chemistry sodium is
again a light metal rather like lithium
and it has a boil and melting point
about 96 degrees so the sodium is a very
very shiny metal and as you see as Neil
cut some off you can see the really
quite nice shiny material really quite
beautiful reacts very very quickly with
air and also with water you form the
oxide layer which is the white or the
hydroxide is a white and crust on the
outside and many of you will know that
if you drop sodium into water it reacts
almost explosively so we're going to
we're going to go outside and additives
and bigger reactions with some of the
the alkali metals so and this is a dog
bowl which is Sam stone where it's very
hard not likely to break unless I drop
all my terms this is sodium the metal
that we cut a minute ago and you can see
there's quite a substantial amount of
the sodium waiting to pop it into the
water and see what we can do with the
reaction okay so here we have a bowl
full of water and maybe Oh a gram of
sodium so let's see what happens see
what this reactions like
so it's reacting really really quite
quickly and really violently with the
water and you can see it's fizzing
around as it's generating lots and lots
of hydrogen gas and they see now the
heat from the reaction is burning away
all that hydrogen which is generating
and you can see the orange sodium flame
yeah that was good that's a chunk of
molten sodium's come out of there right
so let's burn that oh it's on your
camera oh it is too
sodium chloride is transparent for
infrared light and so here we've got a
sheet of sodium chloride that has been
stuck onto a glass vessel so that you
can have infrared light going through it
now this is a broken one which my
students are broken is a bit we got and
we need a needle kneel or prayer
tweezers so you can see here that these
windows have been broken but you can see
an interesting aspect of sodium chloride
that when it breaks it forms cracks that
form at right angles why is that this is
related to the structure of the atoms
inside the crystal which are arranged in
a sort of cubic arrangement I've also
got quite a nice crystal of sodium
chloride over here which I don't know if
you can see it's being turned into a
table lamp and if you switch it on it
lights up so this is just a match mass
of natural sodium chloride from under
the ground somewhere probably in
cheshire or somewhere else like this
where they have large underground salt
night deposits okay so another we got a
lump of sodium and you can see it's
really nice and shiny okay so we're
going to pop that into that big bucket
of water see what the chemical reaction
is okay so here we go
so you can see again see the orange
sodium spectrum as the sodium is getting
excited as the hydrogen's burning all
that heat whoa exciting that's brilliant
so sodium and water excellent reaction
that was great
I like sodium because it's symbol na was
the nickname that my mother whose name
was ena used to use when she was a child
she was known as na so whenever I see of
sodium in the formula I sort of feel a
sort of warm motherly feeling from this